今天這個案例，我看到的時候，第一個想法是：這樣真的行得通嗎？把原本在醫院才能做的眼癌篩檢，直接搬到一般眼鏡行，聽起來有點出乎意料。
嗯，你說到點子上了。我其實也蠻好奇，這種高精度的醫療診斷，下放到這麼普及的地方，診斷品質怎麼確保？會不會出錯？畢竟是眼睛，很重要的。
不過 Eyedentity 這家公司還真的做到了。他們最近剛完成了一輪 130 萬歐元的募資，就是為了把這個 AI 輔助的診斷平台推廣到眼鏡行、眼科診所和醫院。這筆錢可不是小數目。
130 萬歐元，將近 1500 萬瑞典克朗，這數字確實不低。他們能拿到錢，應該是有什麼說服投資人的地方吧？特別是 Norrsken Launcher 和 Karolinska Institutet Innovation 這種機構都進來了。
對，我覺得他們最厲害的，就是活用了現有的基礎設施。公司共同創辦人 Gustav Stålhammar 提到，其實眼鏡行每天都會拍大量的眼底影像，而且找眼鏡行看眼睛的人越來越多。
意思是，他們不是要眼鏡行買一套新的機器，而是利用現成的影像資料來分析？這樣聽起來，成本負擔確實會小很多。
完全正確。他們的 AI 技術就是分析這些已經拍好的眼底影像，然後判斷患者是不是需要轉介給專科醫師。這就省去了額外建置篩檢設備的麻煩。
這點蠻關鍵的。如果還要眼鏡行花大錢買設備，我猜推廣的阻力會大很多。不過，即使只是分析影像，要做到早期發現這種致命眼癌，AI 的準確度要求應該很高吧？
他們專注的是葡萄膜黑色素瘤，一種比較罕見但可能致命的眼癌。這種癌症初期很容易跟良性病變搞混。Eyedentity 說他們的系統能把「假陽性」的轉診率降低 90%。
降低 90%？這個數字如果屬實，那就很厲害了。這不只省下醫療資源，對患者來說，也能減少很多不必要的擔憂。這讓我覺得，他們把 AI 的專長發揮得很好。
所以我覺得，對中小企業或創業者來說，這個案例最大的啟發就是：你是不是能找到一個現有的、普及的服務據點，然後把原本高門檻的專業服務「下放」過去？
「下放」這個詞用得好。就像我開一家小咖啡店，如果能用便宜的方式引進一些原本只有大醫院才有的檢查服務，讓顧客順便在等咖啡的時候做，那確實是新的商機。但關鍵是，你提供的服務要夠簡單、不佔空間、不需額外人力。
沒錯。而且對一般上班族來講，這個概念也能帶進工作。想想看，你手上的哪些專業技能，其實可以拆解成更簡單、更直覺的工具，讓部門內其他同事或甚至客戶也能運用？
例如，我做行銷的，可能有一些複雜的數據分析模型，如果能把它簡化成一個 Excel 表格或線上工具，讓業務同事直接輸入幾個數字就能得出建議，這樣就能提高效率，讓專業知識不再是「孤島」。
對啊。Anna Fredrixon，Norrsken Launcher 的合夥人，她就說這個技術很「聰明」，不需要新的基礎設施，馬上就能推廣。這也說明了，有時候創新的關鍵不是「從零開始」，而是「善用現有」。
嗯，所以他們不僅解決了早期診斷的問題，還避免了醫療系統過載，又能創造新的商業模式。這確實是個多贏的局面。
是啊，這樣聽下來，是不是感覺把專業服務「民主化」其實不難，重點在於找到對的切入點和科技工具。好像也提醒了我們，創新不一定都要很高科技，有時候是換個方式思考。